[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We're all aware of how
important customer experience
is.
And your contact center is
right on the front lines,
with customers
asking for support
from all of the different
channels of communication.
Providing great service on top
of this huge volume of requests
can be hard and intimidating
with a traditional contact
center.
Imagine providing your
customers with immediate 24/7,
AI-driven self-service in a way
that's natural and seamless,
an unforced conversation
that transitions them
to a human agent who can tap
into an AI-powered knowledge
base that allows for quicker,
more accurate resolution.
That's where Google Cloud's
Contact Center AI comes in.
At the core of
the technology are
bots that can talk, listen,
learn, and understand.
This lets them
converse naturally
with customers, resolving
basic issues directly,
and assist via human
agents on complex call,
providing real time,
turn by turn guidance.
Combining the best
of Google Cloud's AI
with the power of
the Genesys Cloud,
Contact Center AI will improve
your customer experience
and increase your operational
efficiency at the same time.
The Genesys and Google
Cloud relationship is
seamless and allows
your AI agent developers
to update variables and
responses on the fly.
You'll have the ability to drive
the discovery of end user needs
in real time.
So you can stop worrying about
compensating ahead of time
for every possible outcome.
You'll create the business
logic and deliver conversation
management so that, by the
time the conversation reaches
a live agent, your custom data
collection environment will
already be established,
bringing it
into the conversation
with the human agent.
Speech-to-Text takes in text
and understands the intent
and uses Google's natural
language processing
to look at intent and
return the entities.
Genesys Architect allows
administrators and contact
center managers to link
together predefined operations
to create simple or
sophisticated menu
applications.
Use it to play audio,
route interactions
to agents, cues, voicemail,
external numbers,
or other flows.
Incorporate advanced features,
such as non-menu digit
collection, data dips,
conditional logic,
and expression editing.
You'll need a Google Cloud
Platform account and a Google
Dialogflow agent to develop
using Genesys Architect.
Dialogflow is Google
Cloud's solution
for creating automated
conversational experiences,
often called bots
or virtual agents.
It's easy to start
building in Dialogflow.
You can import the agent into
Genesys any time you're ready.
Here's how you'd get started.
Create the Google Dialogflow
Platform Service Account
credential.
Obtain the Google
Dialogflow integration
from Genesys AppFoundry.
Create and configure the Genesys
Cloud OAuth client credentials.
Configure the Google Dialogflow
Platform Service Account
credential.
Configure the Genesys
Cloud OAuth credentials,
and then activate
Google Dialogflow
and activate the integration.
Set up a Genesys
Cloud Architect flow,
and then associate
the Google Dialogflow
bot with the Architect flow.
Route a Genesys Cloud phone
number to the Architect flow.
Once your Genesys
integration is complete
and your bot is running, you'll
spot trends and get ahead
of your always growing customer
demand with analytics tools
that allow you to stay in tune.
Today's digital age means
instant gratification.
And Google Cloud's AI technology
enables you to reach customers
immediately, without putting
them through a long phone tree
or placing them on
an extended hold.
Transform your agents
into specialists.
Agents shouldn't waste
time searching for answers,
looking for the most
helpful customer resources,
or even typing up their notes.
Instead, Contact Center AI
will anticipate customer needs
and serve as actionable
insights, making the agent
a better resource for your
customer, your business,
and your bottom line.
Since Google Cloud's Contact
Center AI and Genesys
have partnered, you can now
deliver world class customer
experiences that blend AI and
Google Cloud voice interaction
technologies with
Genesys call center
automation and orchestration.
Come see what it's all about.